digamos que tenemos una función multi
variable efe que depende de x 1 x 2 y
digamos que puede depender de muchísimas
variables verdad digamos hasta una x n
donde x n es digamos donde n es un
número muy muy grande verdad entonces
aquí nuestro nuestro espacio de entradas
es de n dimensiones que puede ser muy
grande y nosotros sabemos cómo calcular
lo vimos en el vídeo anterior cómo
calcular el aplazando de nuestra función
en febrero esto esencialmente es la
divergencia del campo gradiente de efe y
por supuesto el campo gradiente es un
campo vectorial al cual podemos digamos
sacarle la divergencia verdad esta es la
idea de la plastia no y en este vídeo lo
que quiero hacer es mostrarte otra
fórmula de lo que de cómo calcular el
aplasia no digamos que es es una fórmula
mucho más directa para lo cual vamos a
considerar nuestro digamos nuestra
especie de vector que es el este
triangulito nav la verdad que es el que
tiene las derivadas parciales con
respecto a todas las variables verdad
entonces aquí sería
al respecto de x 1 parcial respecto de
x2 y tenemos hasta la parcial respecto
de la última que sería x n verdad
entonces si nosotros queremos calcular
el gradiente de f tenemos que imaginar
que hacemos esta multiplicación del
operador no habla con efe verdad y esto
simplemente sería como una especie de
multiplicación verdad en donde obtenemos
un vector ahora sí en donde tenemos
tenemos la derivada parcial con respecto
de x1 de nuestra función f la derivada
con respecto de x2 de nuestra función
escalar
efe y así continuamos verdad obtenemos
todas las derivadas parciales hasta
llegar a la última derivada parcial que
es respecto de x n de nuestra función f
verdad y aquí es este es el gradiente de
nuestra función ahora bien sólo para
hacerlo rápido voy a borrar esto de aquí
y ahora pensamos en la divergencia que
esencialmente es este
este operador no habla cuando aplicamos
el producto punto con este vector que es
el gradiente de febrer entonces la idea
es que tomamos digamos coordenada
coordenada las multiplicamos y luego las
sumamos verdad entonces cuál sería la
primera tendríamos la derivada con
respecto de x1 de la derivada con
respecto de x1 de f verdad eso sería la
segunda derivada con respecto de x1
ambas veces de nuestra función efe ahora
sí vamos con el segundo término verdad
que tendríamos que sumar tendríamos otra
vez la segunda derivada con respecto de
x2 ambas veces verdad de nuestra función
f y así podríamos ir sumando hasta
llegar al último término verdad que es
esta que es la segunda vamos a corregir
el color que es la segunda derivada con
respecto de la última variable x n de
nuestra función f verdad entonces esta
es una fórmula para el laplace ya no que
de hecho podríamos incluso escribirlo de
forma más compacta
de esta forma utilizando la anotación
sigma entonces aquí tenemos el la
plastia no de f verdad que simplemente
va a ser la suma y esta suma la
expresamos con sigma mayúscula verdad la
suma desde igual a uno hasta n de las
segundas derivadas parciales de f con
respecto de la variable y es verdad esto
es de nuestra función f y esta es una
forma más compacta de escribir al la
plastia no de nuestra función f verdad
entonces a veces la gente utiliza
variables como x jay-z en realidad no
importa el nombre que le demos a las
variables el punto es que es la suma de
las segundas derivadas parciales verdad
y aquí tenemos una
fórmula alterna para lo que es el la
plaza no pero a mí personalmente me
gusta más escribir la plaza no como la
divergencia del gradiente de nuestra
función porque indica muchas más ideas
por ejemplo la idea de donde se
encuentran los máximos y los mínimos
verdad ahora bien esta fórmula anterior
que hemos obtenido es quizás más directa
cuando tenemos que calcular casos
particulares que se nos presentan en el
camino y al menos aquí es mucho más
claro cómo es que la plastia no es es
una extensión de la idea de la segunda
derivada verdad bueno nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo